from Samina is the largest mobile
community for Game of Thrones fans and
it's completely free its feed of great
content chats polls books and more will
fulfill your daily Thrones those on her
on Sammy now you can chat with other
like-minded people participate in polls
read countless theories reviews and much
more
you can also share your own knowledge
theories and predictions in your own
blogs as well as posting your own polls
basically if you like Game of Thrones
civil like this app when you download
the app make sure you add me as a friend
my username is firing blood as you can
tell from the title itself this video
contains major spoilers for the episode
of the season taking into account that
those leaks are from the same sources
for the leaks for the previous episodes
that turned out to be quite accurate
it's safe to say that those certain
leaks are the pure truth however if you
don't want anything spoiled it's time
for you to close this video a week ago
introduced with the leaks through pages
of the final episode that covered only a
few scenes today on the other hand I'm
bringing you a full detail review of
that episode before I start let me give
a quick shout out to freaky dr. Spanish
Game of Thrones related channel who
shared its leak in the first place the
link of his channel as well as the link
of translated pause that basically
translated whole freaky doctor's review
will be in the description down below
the episode starts in King's Landing
where some are arriving to meet with
other important people Lords queens and
kings this huge meeting will take place
in the dragon pit a bit later in the
episode Jon and the nature so basically
bring a captured white in the dragon pet
to prove to other important people that
the danger is real convinced that will
persuade the other lords who send their
armies north the nurse is bringing the
unsullied and the track in case that
Cersei has a trap for her then he places
her armies outside King's Landing doors
Jaime and Bronn oversee King's Landing
as defenses which is when they see the
whole Denny's army outside and they
admire it Tyrion John and others arrive
with the nurse at the capital via ship
was docked Tyrion John Denny a few
Dothraki bloodrider 'he's
Jorah Davos Theon and the Hound quits
the one with white in a cage or evaded
by Brown when they arrive
Brienne and Podrick have arrived as well
Brienne and accounts each other and
Brienne is amazed at the Hound is
somehow alive they talk about Arya and
one of the things that is being said is
when centaur asks her if she should not
be taken care of or instead of being in
the south
Brienne replies with the only person
needing protecting is the one who gets
in her way
the
smiles and says he's not planning to be
nuria's vey well brain and sender are
having a conversation another reunion is
taking place as well
Tyrion and Podrick meet each other after
a long time Podrick still admires and
loves Tyrion even says to him Tyrion
still his lord the majority of them
start arriving at the dragon pit this is
also most likely a moment when this
leaked script page is taking place
it says miss and it looks up and sees a
foreboding piece of the dragon pit
peaking above the foliage line she asks
why did they build it
Tyrion replies oh it was hundreds of
years ago long before my time asks her
Jorah Jorah let's the big slide and says
dragons don't understand the difference
between what something at what isn't
land lives children letting them around
the city was a problem
Tyrion also says something about Aegon
Targaryen Street gray dragons vaguer
murex assemble area in the dread then
there stated that 20 file and histor
guards has rounded D and is heading
their way led by Bronn Brienne and
Podrick are walking on their own but the
tree guards on Brienne end one on pot to
make it clear that they are the guests
of the nation as I already said in one
of my previous videos the dragon pit is
located in King's Landing and therefore
huge amount of Lannister guards is not
surprising other Lords also start to
arrive pretty much everyone has already
arrived but Cersei is not there yet
Tyrion feels like it might be a trap and
looks around sir she arrives with her on
the mountain and Qyburn and they take a
seat Clegane brothers make an eye
contact and the Hound gives that kill
you look but the game ball is not going
to take place on this meeting nor later
in the episode the condom brings the
cage that house is so wide to the middle
of the amphitheatre sir she asks Tyrion
varies his queen as Daenerys is not
there yet which is when Danny arrives on
top of Jurgen and with Drago giving them
company leaving everyone amazed even
Cersei and urine a few months later
while urine is still amazed by a joke on
survival sir similar Spurs the third
dragon
Tyrion then explains why all Lords
queens and kings have been invited to
attend this meeting
meanwhile Theon endurance each other and
urine reveals to him that he did not
kill Yara challenging Theon to rescue
his sister John tries to explain to all
of them that the night king and his army
of the dead are real pointing out that
they need to unite all their armies in
order to stand a chance in the great war
that is coming Cersei doesn't believe
him which is when the Hound opens the
whites cage and white comes out like a
wild beast toward Cersei
but sander has him chained up and is not
able
to reach her Circe's amazed and afraid
at the same time the fountain starts to
demonstrate how white cannot be killed
by normal weapons nor by just chopping
it up bits by bits since it continues to
move even when the hound cuts it up
whites can withstand removal of limp and
even amputated limbs will still move
around on their own this is when John
yells out that there are only two ways
to kill a white the first wire so they
set fire to one White's arms and the arm
stops moving
the second is dragonglass to which john
uses to stab a white resulting with its
death this is the proof that everyone
needs to come together in order to
survive the long night John says there
is only one word that matters in the
great war and it is here
Iran pretends to be afraid and asks how
many of these creatures are there to
beat John says hundreds of thousands
yeren the necks well can they swim and
John responds with no sire and says well
I'm going back to Pyke and leaves as I
said a few moments before yearn is only
pretending to be afraid and while he
said he's heading back to Pyke he's
actually going to ask Souls to hire the
golden company and to bring them with
his iron fleet to Westeros to serve
under search his commands anyways let's
get back to the dragon pit search this
is the danger and says once the long
night is over she must still be a queen
and offers John Snow to be warden of the
north by John Dean swears an oath Danny
in front of everyone
John says I can only serve one Queen and
that queen is the near star garyun sir
she lives in an anger and is unwilling
to collaborate because she is unwilling
to bend the knee to Danny Brienne tries
to calm his Jaime to change search his
mind saying that he needs to come with
the Lannister army to the north to
support the living side Jaime says that
he admires her loyalty towards the
Starks to which Brienne replies with
it's not about loyalty it's about
survival
Jaime has seen all of this and believes
that the Great War is coming and will do
all he can to help them now the Tyrion
Danny and John have seen sources [ __ ] a
response
it means they will not have some of the
south or an army says support in the
north
Tyrion heads to the red keep with the
mountain behind him once he arrives in
the red cape he answers he have a
conversation on how she blames him for
everything the Lannisters have gone
through this is a moment in which this
leaked script page is taking place there
stated that Tyrion stands before his
sister serves two regards him but not
speak Tyrion sits down Cersei then says
I suppose I should not be surprised
she's very much your sort of woman
foreign [ __ ] who doesn't know her place
tyrion responds with a foreign [ __ ] you
can beat or intimidate that must be
difficult for you
Cersei replies and so you brought her
here and her pet northerner who might
suppose she convinced bow down sir she's
talking about the nearest send the pet
North owner would be John Snow who bent
the knee to the mother of dragons at
this point Don Tyrion is pretty much
explaining to Cersei how long she's
about her belief that he's been trying
to destroy their family well it's
actually quite opposite Tyrion says that
he is the one who prevented the nearest
from attacking his Landing with dragons
and therefore he's the only reason
Cersei still alive
Tyrion says the nurse didn't want to
negotiate she didn't want to bring you
words she wanted to bring you fire and
blood until I advised her otherwise if
I'm so committed to destroying my family
then why are you still here it's a story
you've been telling yourself since I was
born but it's not true I don't want to
destroy our family I never have
then Tyrion says if I'm so evil why
don't you order the mountain to kill me
sir she doesn't give a command because
she's interested in what he will say
next
Tyrion also finds out that she's
pregnant Tyrion basically decides to
drink wine and Cersei doesn't so he
called her out saying she doesn't drink
because she is pregnant
Cersei doesn't admit this nor does she
denied but her facial expression gives
it away after having quite a long
conversation Tyrion then heads out with
Cersei to meet the rest of the people
that were in the dragon pit Cersei says
that the conversation is her brother
Tyrion has changed her mind and promises
that she will send troops north to help
against the army of the dead as probably
most of your guests sir sees lying she
does not intend to support the living
side and will not send her troops north
later in the episode Jaime and Cersei
have a conversation about the upcoming
war
Jaime doesn't know that Cersei has no
intention on sending her army north and
doesn't know that she basically wants
the army of the Dead to kill the
northern army send their allies Jaime's
looking at a map of the north and starts
gathering the Leinster army to get ready
for a long travel when Cersei asks him
what he is doing
Jaime replies I'm getting ready to go
north with the army this is a moment in
which Cersei reveals her true intentions
to Jaime
she firstly reveals that she has no
intention of sending her army north and
says they have dragons and troops they
can handle it then she tells Jaime that
she has obtained an agreement with urine
while he pretended to be a coward who is
heading back to Pyke he actually went
with his arm fleet to us
to Harn bring the golden company to
Westeros on her behalf
upon hearing out sir such two intentions
Jimmy will finally figure out who his
sister and la virtual is which will
result with Jaime finally leaving Cersei
okay guys this would be about the first
half of an episode while the other half
is currently in the process and will be
released as soon as possible make sure
you stay tuned for the second part
because it contains the first scenes of
Rhaegar Targaryen in series as well as
death of one major character and most
importantly the last scene of the
episode that will be nothing less than
epic